Are you embarrassed at the gym You're
Not Alone millions of americans can't
enjoy their workouts with all the stairs
and glares but now There's a better way
introducing the new Private gym body
tarp the one and only body tarp That's
designed exclusively for you  body work
out with confidence as the Private gym
body tarp takes you from this to this
finally a secluded workout that No one
can see use it with free weights
elliptical even in the shower just
listen to what people are saying about
the Private gym body tarp I  was
self-conscious about lifting weights but
The Body tarp covers my body with a tarp
i can't Imagine doing Yoga without it it
even has a Pocket for your mp3 player
everyone's using the Private gym body
tarp from beginners to personal trainers
even professional bodybuilders  you got
this Man You got it now Anyone can work
out comfortably and privately byy the
Private gym body tarp
today